Dear gentlemen, Science has a confession.
Your life actually began as a female.
Well, phenotypically or physically speaking that is,
though some prefer to call this stage gender neutral.
As you might know,
two people mate, they each combine half of their
genetic information together;
23 chromosomes each. One pair of these
chromosomes helps to determine your sex.
If you're female you contain two X
chromosomes one from your mother and one
from your father
while males have one X and one Y
chromosome. At the moment of conception
you were of course male or female based
on your jeans
but the Y chromosome doesn't kick in
right away. In fact, the first five to six
weeks of embryonic development are
attributed to the X chromosome alone
and females grow from embryo to fully
developed to the influence of
only the X chromosome. So what does the Y
chromosome do?
Once activated, one of the genes on the Y
chromosome
known as the SRY gene has two functions:
to inhibit certain features of the X
chromosome
and to impose through dominance the
physiological traits that a male must
have.
The ovaries descend and become the testes
and the labia fuses to create the scrotum.
If you're a male, take a look. Though it's
more pronounced in some and then
others, you'll likely notice a line or
ridge of tissue on the scrotum
which is called the 'scrotal raphe'. The
skin of the scrotum and penis
are zipped up like a zipper as the
layers of cells develop in the embryo.
And the mail variant of the clitoris?
Yep, that's the penis. If the Y chromosome
does not become activated for some
reason
then the female phenotype or physical
appearance will persist in a male.
Power added, this is also part of the
reason males have nipples.
The nipples form before the activation
of the Y chromosome
and SRY gene and thus remain through
development and life.
But, you don't develop breasts. Sorry. Got a
burning question you want answered?
Ask it in the comments or on Facebook and
Twitter and subscribe for more weekly
science videos.